what do I think about Zazzle so I got a
great question one of my google+ viewers
William loved you guys who wrote in to
say hello Evan I would really like to
hear your opinion on print-on-demand
websites such as zazzle and Spreadshirt
I see a lot of artists and entrepreneurs
using their services I personally have
decided to go down a different path
because for me I feel it's not the right
way to do business but I think would
make for an interesting discussion if
you can give your thoughts on it
so William this will be an interesting
discussion unfortunately in one way
because you know unless you want to make
a video response I'd love to see that
but I'm actually a fan of Zazzle and
I'll tell you why you're not going to
make millions of dollars selling stuff
on zazen ok but that's not the point the
point is [ __ ] is to help you get
started this is why you use dazzle is to
help you launch your business if you're
trying to launch a t-shirt line okay so
you want to launch a new brand of
t-shirts the way that most entrepreneurs
you have to go and buy t-shirts right
you have to stock up on inventory so you
create your design and then you have to
go and get men's and women's from extra
small to three XL and you're carrying
lots of inventory if you're waiting for
in order to come and then you're going
to go put put out that order right it's
like some guy comes as hey I like that
shirt I want to buy one you gotta go
print one that's going to be super
expensive for you you're not going to
make any money off it so that the way to
make money is to sell a thousand of them
five thousand of them 10 thousand of
them make that kind of order because
then the cost per shirt comes down to
price where you can make money but this
is the big but the big problem is that
you don't know which shirts going to
sell or not and so many people take the
little money that they have right now
assume when money is important to you
you don't have a ton of reserves built
up you can't blow this cash whatever
money you spend has to pay off right
they blow their money on that first lund
that first run that first line and then
it doesn't sell and you're stuck with
all these shirts that in your garage so
why I love Zazzle is because it allows
you to test out your concept without
spend
any money on it right you may have 20
designs for shirt ideas maybe two of
them will be amazing and the other 18
won't work out but you don't know until
you test you may think they're all
amazing you know see if the market wants
to sews as allows you to put them online
right you put them online you may make
$1 a shirt you make $0.50 a shirt it
doesn't matter what you're doing is
testing the concept and also building a
customer base so you put them online you
promote them like you would promote your
regular shirts and you see what does
well if you can sell a hundred shirts on
Zazzle now you can talk about having
justification to go out and create an
order right and and spend money to buy a
thousand shirts where you can start
making some money but if you can't sell
a hundred shirts on Zazzle then why
would you go out and order a thousand
shirts you're going to lose your money
on it so I love zazen for early-stage
for proving a concept for showing that
this thing works that people actually
care that people will actually buy your
product and then taking the winning
ideas and going out and launch an online
with that that's why I love Zazzle
believe those you're watching like the
video support me by clicking the link in
the description you can leave a comment
let me know what you think or click on
my face subscribe to the channel thank
you so much I'll see you soon